hello everyone and welcome to another
great game from round 7 of this year's
Norway chess it is Wesley Seoul versus
and it's one of those games where you
don't make a mistake but you still lose
somehow uh how how does this happening
just well uh your opponent constantly
makes a move that's a little bit better
than the move you've made previously and
you know the advantage the advantages
just keep stacking up and at some point
after some 10 or 20 moves uh it uh you
know reaches that breaking point where
you actually have enough advantage to
win the game so uh it's not that we will
have some sort of a crazy pause the
video moment but it's just a very very
slow positional outplay that we are
discussing and we will already have a
completely new game as of move seven so
uh also something to enjoy as the
opening of choice is the Queen's Gambit
accepted so let's check it out Wesley
has the white pieces and he opens with
D4 we have Pawn to D5 uh C4 and the D
captures and C for the Queen's Gambit
accepted as advertised with 4 onto E4
the central variation and pawn to E5 of
course now with white captures you can
play Queen captures on D1 so Knight to
F3 and now uh e captures on D4 we have
Bishop captures and C4 and now Knights
the C6 we have castles and now okay the
position is a fairly known one at Bishop
T6 is the main move here other possible
which there are some like Bishop to C5
also Knight to F6 has been played and
some other moves that have been played
less frequently but the move up to
Saturn plays uh Queen to F6 has only
been played once uh and here uh the the
game continued with fonte E5 but then
Queen to G6 happens and black also has
some very nice pressure against the
white king but in the game uh after this
queen to F6 move uh Wesley just played
Queen to G5 and it is now already as of
move seven that we have a completely new
game so Queen to G6 now the bishop has
to be a little bit careful you don't
only the Knight is defending it uh so
Knight beat the D2 adding another at
Defender to this night so even if this
one gets eliminated this one will take
his place and also you are defending the
E4 Pawn so Bishop to E7 trying to trade
over the Bishops and the bishop back to
F4 putting pressure on the C7 Pawn
Knight to F6 offering the C7 Pawn for
the E4 pawn and now Bishop to B5 and now
we get this very very tricky position
where uh black sort of can capture an E4
but it's not uh something that you want
to play if Knight captures an E4 then
comes Knight to E5 uh hence Bishop to B5
on the previous move and the queen is
attacked the Knight cannot move uh it's
a very uh crazy position but you will
not have a great time for example if
Queen to have five Knight captures and
E4 can be played even the immediate
Knight captures and C6 can be played and
then if Queen captures on B5 you play
Knight captures and E7 uh you ruin
Black's uh castling for example with
Knight captures Queen captures you will
have to pick up the Knight because
otherwise you just lose then after King
captures Rook fd1 check and already this
is pretty pretty much game over so
instead after Bishop to B5 Bishop to D6
and now Bishop back to G3
and here uh not Rebecca needs to decide
whether he wants to trade and then try
to maybe play Knights to G for Queen H6
and somehow Checkmate the white king
this way if he can ever get rid of the
knight from F3 or does he want to play
something like Knight stage five and
Knight to H5 is a fun line the bishop
captures and G3 was played I'm just
going to show you what happens if you go
for something like Knight to H5 as the
Knight also can come to F4 but here okay
you have a couple of moves to choose
from probably Knight captures
um on D4 is what would happen and here
okay black would just Castle Knight
characters and C6 uh B captures on C6
and now Bishop captures and C6 attacking
the rook and aid but now Bishop to G4
attacks the queen and uh after a move
like Queen to C2 you're gonna play Rook
to B8 develop the the rook and okay you
have very nice development for the price
of one pawn and even if Bishop captures
let's say uh C captures and Ponte F3 you
don't have anything to worry about if uh
okay the bishop now has to move even if
of the H3 going for checkmate you can
just move the Knight the queen nicely
defends the pawn so everything is
perfectly fine if Rook have to C8 puts a
nice pressure on the C file just Bush up
to D5 so this is um you know perfectly
playable so Knight to H5 uh it is a is
an idea uh but uh of course the line
that we've shown is in force you can
just trade on D6 for example Bishop
capture C captures and now Knights to H4
and then we get this crazy position
Queen to each six and who knows what's
uh what's really happening here uh they
want none of that Bishop captures and G3
was played with h captors and now
castles we have rooked the C1 nicely
developing and now Knights the G4 so
like we said if uh can somehow get rid
of Wesley's Knight and F3 then Checkmate
is near but that's easier said than done
uh one of the ways uh uh another could
attempt this is by playing Knight to E5
at some point this will force a trade of
at least one of the knights so the
bishop captures on C6 uh we have B
captures and now Queen to A4 putting
pressure on that um uh C6 pawn and now
while you would probably expect Bishop
to D7 here uh yes then Queen captures
and D4 so uh and another really works
but it could be an interesting try for
example Bishop D7 Queen captures and
then you play Rook F2 d8 could be could
be very nice uh then maybe at some point
maybe Queen H6 you can pick up the
Knight here the Knight will not be able
to move but that's all of course uh you
know those are ideas that are not really
possible uh you just uh I mean you might
try and get an active play out of those
ideas but instead Queen to H6 was played
yeah another big just gives up the
opponent Z6 and this is his idea Rook
captures in C6 attacks the queen here
now Bishop to D7 now he offers a queen
trade Rook captures an H6 Bishop
captures an A4 and now Rook the H5 Rook
Dage four also looks very nice but the
Knight can simply uh be defended by the
bishop so Rook H5 and now Knight back to
F6 uh there's also a very fine line with
Ponte F5 uh defending the Knight and
trying to open up the a DF file and then
if row captures on F5 you can even
temporarily give up a pawn here for Pawn
to D3 and this Pawn it's a past D pawn
it will be incredibly uh powerful here
if something like Rook to C1 going after
the pawn even Bishop to C2 can be played
uh and so on I mean a lot a lot of
poison in this position uh but instead
Knight back to F6 by another back we
have Rook back to A5 attacks the bishop
and the bishop to C2 now now putting
pressure on that E4 Pawn uh Pawn to E5
and Knight to E4 we have rooked the C1
attacking the bishop and now not Bishop
to D3 uh Bishop to D3 although uh I mean
it'd be great if you didn't have to
trade the Knight for Bishop but if you
try to rescue the bishop then Knights
the E1 and your Bishop has no squares
you're gonna have to play Knight
captures on D2 then Knight captures on
D3 and okay you'll try to defend the
pawn but then Pawn to F3 and then the
Knight is trapped you will lose the
Knight even King to F2 to E2 captures is
possible so you do not have time at uh
defend the C7 one point you will have to
save the Knight with something like
Knight's day E4 and then the Rook will
just uh capture the pawn so not not
great so that's why of course Bishop to
D3 was not played even though you know
you really want to play this move Knight
captures on D2 now Wesley gets rid of
the bishop and now Knight captures an F3
with check we have G captures on F3 and
now Pawn to F6 going after the E5 Pawn
uh again you could play Rook F to C8
trying to defend the pawn but then Pawn
to F4 and blacks Rooks are absolutely
disgusting here there is no activity you
cannot do anything here the C5 square is
covered you can't even push C5 uh best
you would have is to play something like
D3 and I'll try and force um
uh White uh to move the Rook from the C
file and of course white will do this
then you get to push the C Pawn real
captures let's say Pawn to C4 but now
Rook to D7 going after the A7 pawn and
he found the A7 uh even Pawn to F5 and
the white is completely dominating this
position so instead after G captures an
F3 Pawn to F6 was attempted by another
back and now Rook captures on C7 we have
rooked the F7 and now Rook captures on
F7 King captures and E captures on F6 uh
and here uh noderbeck is in uh is in a
lot of trouble the problem with the
recaping it doesn't matter what you
capture with if you play King captures
uh just Rook D5 and now you're just done
too much material if Rook the B8 you're
gonna defend the pawn and even if Rook
to B4 to defend uh the the D4 Pawn now
you will play King to F1 now the king
comes to D3 you pick up the pawn and or
you're already up material you're gonna
pick up another Point you're gonna be up
too much material and if King is six you
can even play Rook A5 you go after the
pawn and the fruit of the B7 defending
the pawn now you go after this Pawn
let's say Rook to D7 you're gonna play
King to D3 let's say H5 H6 F4 you're
gonna put your opponents on optimal
squares and then at some point just win
the spawn uh no way uh black can really
stop this D5 square has been taken away
from the black king you cannot defend it
so that that's one way to do it if you
play King captures so another big tries
one last uh one last idea a rook to d8
even though he's done material he has to
pass deep on and if he can push it it's
game over but uh Wesley not want to be
tricked easily just plays King the F1
and it's a it's a really uh sign of a
great player because the Rook captures
an A7 comes with check and it's even
even Rook captures an E7 is winning but
King to F1 is just um you know it's it
really is a gentleman's move uh I to
give you an example of Rook captures an
A7 okay King captures on F6 now King to
F1 let's say D3 uh King T1 and now you
get this Rook to E8 with check because
the Rook now wants to go to E2 you
cannot keep pushing the pawn uh King to
D2 Rook to E2 with check and now King
captures on D3 and there are two choices
here one is the capture on fb1 is the
captron B2 but none of them really work
if you capture on B2 then uh uh uh King
will defend the df2 pawn and uh not a
lot to be done here you're still down
two pawns a pawn will now start marching
forward and that's it and if you capture
this Pawn it's not much better Pawn to
B4 is coming you can even give up all of
these pawns you don't really care
because white is just too fast King
captures with check King to C4 Rook
captures and G3 but already Pawn to B5
is here you you cannot go behind the
pawn you have to waste an additional
Tempo uh B6 you're gonna play Rook to B1
King to C5 and now if black starts
pushing as well which is basically
Black's only counter idea uh Pawn to B7
and if Pawn to H4 now you run into the
very unpleasant Rook to A6 check uh King
goes any Square doesn't really matter
Rook to B6 and the pawn promotes after a
few checks are given for those of you
who do not believe me here we can give a
few checks and after King the D2 The
Rook has nowhere to go or rather you
will have to give up The Rook otherwise
the queen is coming into the game so
that's why Rook uh captures an A7 check
is winning but with the a true gentleman
uh of course in classical chess uh just
plays King to F1 and now another back
knows it is all over he played D3 ways
to play King T1 and he was in this
position on move 28 that Northern back
Abdul Sato resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so truly
incredible uh you might think okay 28
moves that's some sort of a Morpheus
miniature you know with blazing
sacrifices but no it's a you know they
traded pieces the whistle went into a
better end game being up on up uh and a
little by little he accumulated his
advantages and just uh you know took uh
took the whole three points uh so yeah
here he resigned because of the exact
same idea that we've covered now only
without wasting a move on no captures on
A7 basically Rook d8 chocolate taking to
D2 again we get Rook D2 with checking
captures on D3 and everything else is
the same doesn't really matter
uh black will have to waste an
additional move uh capturing this at
some point and Wesley will have to waste
an additional move capturing this at
some point so you know uh no point in
even trying not to Rick knows this and
he uh just resigns the game here uh so
yeah really nicely done by Wesley uh
Notre back uh I I love it when he goes
and uh these young players when they go
for the Queen's Gambit accepted uh it is
uh it's uh you know in the olden days
they said that the Queen's gamut is the
only Gambit that's not really a Gambit
because you're not gambiting anything uh
if black takes it uh he will really have
to fight for his life even though of
course you can play it I mean you can
play anything uh but it's not I mean
it's not easy especially against a
player like Wesley uh who you know is
not a classical world champion not a
rapid world champion not a Blitz World
Champion but he is a official random
world champion uh and you know that uh
definitely tells you a lot about you
know uh going to unexplored areas with
Wesley uh he will he will just destroy
you uh so yeah for those of you who
haven't seen my previous video uh here
are the uh here are the mutual
Encounters this is round seven so
fabulos to go cash in Armageddon even
though Fabio was completely winning uh
that's the previous game that I've
covered uh fabul lost on time in an
absolutely crazy Queen important end
game Wesley defeated another big In
classical so plus three points for
Wesley Hikaru defeated chocolate in
Armageddon Magnus defeated alireza also
in Armageddon Magnus won all of his
matches after losing that game to Fabi
but he uh won all of them in Armageddon
so not a lot of points for him and
danish defeated tari in classical chess
so here are the standings for those of
you who haven't seen it Fab is still in
the lead Hikaru uh
Hikaru and the Fabi if they do well in
round eight in round nine they will be
fighting for first place as they will
meet there so probably a winning
classical in the final round that will
mean a victory in the tournament then we
in third place Wesley gukash and then is
sharing with 10 points fourth and fifth
alireza and six with nine and a half
then Magnus and Shockley are sharing
seven and eight with nine another back
with six and Aryan tari last place with
three points and the live uh ratings if
you guys haven't seen them fob is still
in number two uh over to kikaru then now
there is a Hikaru Nepal Gary Wesley
Anand Anand just keeping that Ninth
Place like you know he he's just amazing
at his age he just you know still in top
10 classical chess what a guy uh and you
know pretty much everything else is the
same I will keep you guys informed uh
when uh more classical games will be
played so that's the game and a little
bit of extra info info about um you know
the event hope you guys enjoyed that I
would like to thank David kimuran David
gasparian Brandon fukuda Ricky Johnson
and father for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event uh until it finishes
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day